à près de deux kilomètres sous terre ce
forage récupère de l'eau dans un
réservoir un lien naturel capté à 65°
elle va ensuite permettre de chauffer
l'eau du chauffage urbain de la ville de
vélizy villacoublay sur le principe de
la géothermie on va chercher cette
chaleur de la terre on sort et qui
permet de chauffer des réseaux et
ensuite on réinjecte on a toujours
depuis un puis deux de soutirage et un
puits de réinjection on réinjecte donc
l'eau froide qui a perdu ses calories
puisque on la sort à 65 degrés et un
arrêt injecte à peu près à 20 degrés
après deux ans de travaux la centrale
est aujourd'hui mise en service douze
mille logements en chauffage collectif
et entreprises de vélizy villacoublay en
sont aujourd'hui bénéficiaire dès
aujourd'hui les vénusiens mon gagné
plusieurs centaines d'euros sur leur
facture de chauffage puisqu'on passe au
niveau du mégawatt 225 euros le mégawatt
hier à 93 euros aujourd'hui donc là et
c'est pas fini donc finalement on à
améliorer le cadre de vie ont la
meilleure la protection de notre planète
et en même temps
on améliore aussi le quotidien et la fin
de mois de tous les visuels
détenu à 80% par angie et 20 % par la
ville la centrale à bénéficier d'un
soutien financier de la région
ile-de-france et de l'ademe à hauteur de
9 millions coût total du projet 25
millions d'euros